bassem youssef is a sensation in the
Arab world he caught his hugely popular
weekly satire show el been an egg or the
program mules have broke onto the scene
after the Revolution in 2011 and became
a phenomenon he shot Barb's at Egypt's
leaders and made fun of his own
vulnerability I didn't do [ __ ] dear
viewers like if you're watching us now
it means that the show has not yet been
cancelled in the dynamic Matt Manoj and
now he says that it has I'm really sorry
for all this tension beth ann ebon
israeli that i always have to be
watching myself that to me my protectee
mean that i have to worry about my
personal safety ok to nettle holiday and
alfin if in a state like the data Yosef
has frequently had to answer to
authorities he's been investigated for
insulting Egypt's president his first
television show was pulled last year it
was then revived by another channel and
also carried on deutsche welle
but during the run-up to the Egyptian
elections the show was suspended and now
it's not coming back Lattimore mind the
more I think it's a real chain for Egypt
that this had to happen and we have full
respect for bassem youssef and his team
who had really hard times in the last
weeks and month and it's really sad and
we hope to continue also with Buffum
yusup in another way so we are ready
from deutsche welle it's still unclear
whether Yosef will return to television
screens he says he doesn't want to
produce the show outside Egypt and that
he's too tired to move to another
channel